miley cyrus
and she said
just be yourself and have fun
selena gomez pulling out her best miley
cyrus impression but one reason i'm
really excited to host snl is because
i'm single
and
and
i've heard that snl is a great place to
find romance
and mocking her dating life in her snl
hosting debut i feel like you could be
able to see in my face and i love what
i'm doing right now a smiling selena
hits the 8-h stage to deliver a
joke-packed monologue referencing her
disney days i also asked one of my
oldest friends miley cyrus
and she said
just be yourself and have fun
i was like miley is that just an excuse
for me to do an impression of you on the
show and she was like
hell yeah i'm miley cyrus
yeah it's a pretty good impression it
was so awesome then she reflects on how
hard it's been for her to date and that
saturday night live might be the place
to meet a guy
seeing how emma stone scarlett johansson
and kim kardashian all met their current
partners there so i just want to put it
out in the universe that i'm manifesting
love and i would like to say that i'm
looking for my soulmate but at this
point i will take
anyone uh
i'll do it
what
be with you like you said i'll do it
oh
no no
no
no
but you just said you'd take anyone no
yeah but i was just sort of joking i
just don't really think that's gonna be
our journey i'm sorry
love's been on selena's mind a lot
lately serving as constant inspo for her
tick tocks last time i was single i was
24 and the dating pool was everyone and
now it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that
no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single it's a
real thing it's fine
[Music]
what is your dating range lately 31 to
coffin
[Music]
and there's more tick-tocking where that
came from because selena snuck in one
for her followers backstage at
rockefeller center
[Music]
in a minute i'm gonna need a sentimental
man a woman to pump me up feeling fussy
walking in my valencia sees trying to
bring out the fabulous cause
before stepping out and looking at
stunning at the after party where who
knows maybe she met her match mr no jeff
thank you
thank you of course baby you know i'm so
sorry these men out here harassing you
it's just unacceptable boo you're just
out here doing your job you know
damn
but um
i
i'll i'll do it
honestly it's kind of a vibe but let's
see how the after party goes